ございます
th
me
びっくりしたほら耳が痛いよかもよ
ゾゾイ
なんでここにいるの君についてきたんだよ
医大の玄武
いい感じる以下に向かいますからかパターンとっておきましょう
ん
持っています
ちょっとになんでここにいるんだ
君のお尻の穴から出てきたんだよそれはちょっと違いますよ見つめてる方飼っ
by の毎回は気になりません
非常になんでここにいるの君にこっそりついてきたんだよ
マイですはそんな感じで行けました年収これもしかしていたバー販売には短寸
また違うパターンねってことにしますそうでなんかなんだろ自然ながありそうな感じで
言ってをするん
なきゃって
いいですかいいよありそうな感じ
ん
いえなかでしょ家流れそのキュッキュッ
いきますよ
そうですねなんでここに言うなそこの鍵が開いてだから入ってきたんだよ
まぁそんな感じですね私は
なんか単調下君いや全然全然いっすよ全然いいんですけどちょっと僕もん
学校に行かなきゃいけないんでなるほどヘッドでしょ
こんなんでいいかねえねえこんなんでいいんですかねいやいいじゃんか
ブーバーストーリっ
もっとストーリー的なやつにしたかったんですよ
それなんか原稿とかつくんないと難しい大丈夫です何でいきますよね big
ねっ
だけど家構えてねー
ああああああ
me
dea